white on the roll sprays it out to smart
one more to Tatum
driving against Maxi no whistle Tatum
got it butter the crowd wanted a push
off on Tatum uses that right arm backs
Maxie off
calmly drains the three Doc is upset
this this to me could have been an
offensive foul right there that is an
offensive foul to me that's a that's a
foul
sure look that way
but a big time shot in the aftermath
by Jason Tatum
had two points in the first half sitting
on 24 right now none bigger
than those three
[Music]
and B pulleys his way inside out to
harden for the three got it
[Applause]
Celtics are gonna play Joe Missoula is
going to let them go down by one 10
seconds to play
[Applause]
Tatum against Harris
Tatum smart
got it did it count I don't think he got
it all did not get it off in time it
appeared it appeared to be late they're
going to review it by rule because it
went through the basket as the bomb
expired
you can tell by the crown reaction that
he didn't get it off in time
[Applause]
yeah
they took way too long Doris to get into
their action there's no question about
it and there's no doubt that's not even
close
the 76ers battle back
and a clutch three ball by James Harden
ends up being the decisive stroke the
mask is unsuccessful
so the 76ers Eve in the series at two
games a piece
James Harden looked like James Harden
game one it wasn't 45 it was 42 and this
was the biggest flick of the wrist Doris
you peel off the corner because you
don't want him B to beat you but you're
putting yourself in a position for a
long closeout watch Jalen Brown come off
that strong side corner embiid makes the
right play The Challenge not good enough
James with a big time game and a big
time delivery for the former MVP this
three ball was for his special
recovering guest John Howe it was for Dr
J looking and watching from above in one
of the Suites here and the biggest shot
of the season so far comes from that guy
James Harden
he received